[Music]
oh my goodness it's a classic steve
martin's classic king tut i know king
tut though
good good we're on the same page again
but the song talks about the popularity
of the egyptian pharaoh and his
treasures and now discovering king tut's
tomb is coming to las vegas tom zahler
of imaginext
exhibitions joins us to talk about that
thank you so much for being here tonight
thanks for being inviting me i love it
and you guys have done so many things in
las vegas already most notably are the
one i think most people are familiar
familiar with bodies yeah we first i've
been operating different exhibitions in
las vegas since 2000 the first one was
titanic at the real yeah long time ago
and moved it to tropicana did bodies of
tropicana did a bunch of different
exhibitions all over town had a gallery
at venetian had a um uh something in
planet hollywood for a little while did
andy warhol bellagio so we've been we
sort of you know uh
i love these exhibition spaces right
they allow you to tell a story in the
sort of three-dimensional way and this
town is perfect for it people are here
they want to be entertained you can you
can drink so much you can go to the pool
so much you know they need something
else to do it's a little cerebral
stimulation in the process of everything
else you need to keep make sure your
mind's still working yeah exactly you
have rare photographs that valley
valleys are rarely seen at valleys also
there is um
real bodies and then we just opened this
week a lounge called the cabin of
curiosities and if you time it right and
you make a reservation you can go into
the speakeasy which is called the lock
in order to get into the lock you have
to
meet the locksmith
and solve a code which then opens the
safe door which opens the access a
reverse escape room if you will but you
escape to the bar yeah so you escape
from one bar to another bar so it's
actually very nice again testing your
cerebral skin right off the bat and
that's located where that's at valley so
real bodies
um rarely seen and the cabin of
curiosity and the lock are all at ballet
okay and king tut now where would you
put a king cutting exhibit
it has to be the luxor right i mean it
kind of fits with it yes absolutely and
that's coming in august yeah so this is
the 100th anniversary of the discovery
of king tut's tomb will be in november
um so howard carter was a egyptologist
who
was was looking for this tomb for seven
years
and his funder lord canarvin english guy
actually if you know downton abbey the
the uh
the house they live in that's
carnarvon's house okay it's your little
sidebar there but he um he's like look
carter this is the last year if you
don't do it this year i'm cutting you
off and that was the year in the valley
of the kings he you know his stumbled
upon this tomb and and it's it's
surely the most famous um tomb ever
uncovered right it's why king tut is
famous really yeah because king ted's
story isn't i mean the story of the of
this boy king isn't really that
interesting right more interesting
stories but because the tomb was so
intact yeah and there was such wonderful
things like carter is quoted as saying
he kind of looks through this thing and
they say what do you see do you see
things he said oh i see things i see
wonderful things it was just because
nobody had you know on everything had
been looted right so we're going to
recreate that moment we're going to in
luxor we're going to create this this
king tut story and because it's the
100th anniversary we're going to sort of
honor that
look at it through howard carter's lens
we're going to tell the story but we're
going to do it in a really cool some
cool technology ways and with objects
that have been
all made by egyptian artisans and sort
of recreate this tell the story i love
that it's more of an experience than
people have seen before and that's
august it's going to be at the end of
august end of august august 26th all
right tom thanks so much for being here
today i really appreciate it look